À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Je le sens d'ici.
Tu te demandes sûrement
ce que tu es en train d'écouter.
Cher auditeur,
tu vas découvrir une aventure
débordante de rebondissements
et de sauts dans le temps,
de personnages énergiques
et charismatiques.
Mais notre aventure commence
de nos jours,
avec un jeune homme
sans énergie, ni charisme.
Nous sommes dans la chambre
de Thomas.
Allez, Thomas, ça va aller.
Non, Maman,
je peux pas surmonter ça !
- Je suis amoureux d'elle !
- T'en fais trop.
Elle était pas si incroyable.
Tu mérites mieux.
Tu l'as jamais vue, Maman.
Oui, bah, montre-moi une photo.
Waouh ! Le canon !
C'est une mannequin
ou un truc comme ça, non ?
C'est quoi, son prénom ?
Elle s'appelle Iris
et elle me manque tellement.
Ne t'inquiète pas,
elle va revenir.
Regarde son nouveau copain
à côté d'elle,
il est trop moche.
C'est moi, Maman.
Ah... Oui, c'est vrai.
Elle a rompu comment ?
Elle a disparu
du jour au lendemain,
sans donner de nouvelles,
pas un message, pas une lettre.
Elle t'a fait une Papa, quoi.
Mais... Attends...
- T'es pas sûr qu'elle a rompu ?
- Comment ça ?
Si ça se trouve,
elle a disparu !
elle est juste morte !
Iris est morte ?
Oh, ça va !
Elle est vivante,
c'est une catastrophe,
elle est morte,
c'est une catastrophe...
Bon, écoute, Thomas,
il est temps de passer
à autre chose.
- Ça fait quoi, 1 semaine ?
- 1 mois.
1 mois et t'es encore en train
de chialer ?
Il faut aller de l'avant !
T'es mon fils et j'aime pas
te voir comme ça.
Tu sais ce qui pourrait
te requinquer ?
Voler de tes propres ailes.
T'as pensé à avoir
ton propre chez-toi ?
- Tu me vires, Maman ?
- Mais non !
Je dis ça pour toi !
Ça te ferait pas plaisir
d'avoir ton propre chez-toi ?
Et puis moi,
j'aurais mon propre chez-moi.
- Mais ça change rien ?
- Mais si !
Tu pourrais voir tes copains
et jouer à tes jeux
et moi, je pourrais voir
mes copains et jouer à mes jeux.
Mais Maman, j'ai pas de copains.
Eh bah moi, j'en ai plein.
Si ça se trouve, il existe
une fille qui fait pas attention
au physique et qui attend que
de rencontrer un gentil garçon
comme toi et qui cherche
un colocataire.
J'ai déjà sélectionné
quelques annonces.
Tiens, regarde celle-là.
Oui, bon ça va ! J'arrive !
Oh, Iris...
T'étais la femme de ma vie.
Thomas, t'as un petit copain
qui est venu te rendre visite !
- Quoi ?
- Bonjour, cher humain.
Mais Maman...
Maman, c'est un robot !
Bah, comment tu parles
de tes petits copains ?
C'est pas gentil !
Excuse-le, il est chamboulé.
Une fille mieux que lui
l'a quitté.
- Je comprends.
- Mais Maman !
C'est pas du tout un ami à moi !
C'est... C'est un robot !
- C'est une machine !
- Pas du tout.
- Je suis un humain.
- Ah, tu vois !
Mais non, mais non !
Il est en métal !
- Il porte même pas d'habits !
- Tu n'as aucune preuve.
Bien sûr que j'ai des preuves,
t'es tout en métal !
Écoute le bruit que tu fais !
Ah ! Ma main !
On fait exactement
le même bruit.
Effectivement, on ne fait pas
le même bruit, je suis démasqué.
- J'avoue, je suis un robot.
- Ah, bah merci !
C'est super douloureux !
Tu vois, Maman, c'est un robot !
Bon, écoutez, moi, j'y connais
rien avec vos Snapchat, là,
vos Facedebook, faites pas
de bêtises, les garçons.
- Promis ! Merci, Madame.
- Quoi ?
Mais parle pas à ma mère
comme si t'étais mon pote !
Oh putain,
je parle à une machine.
- Bon, où est Iris ?
- Quoi ?
- Quoi, tu... Tu connais Iris ?
- Elle est ici ?
Non, non, non, ça fait des mois
qu'elle donne plus de nouvelles.
Tu la connais d'où ?
Elle t'a parlé de moi
récemment ?
Mmh, je vois, elle a dû
changer de temporalité.
- Ça ne m'arrange pas.
- Quoi ?
J'ai capté son empreinte
à une autre époque.
- Elle doit se trouver là-bas.
- Quoi ?
Désolé du dérangement,
bonne continuation
dans tous vos formidables
projets !
Retemporalisation dans 5...
- Attends !
- 4...
- Attends, attends !
- 3... 2... 1...
Tu sais où est Iris ?
Ne pars pas ! Eh !
Eh, tu m'écoutes ! Waouh !
Qu'est-ce qui vient
de se passer ?
On est où, là ?
À la vue des arbres au loin,
de l'étendue d'herbe
et de la vue dégagée, je dirais
qu'on est dans une clairière.
Oui, je vois bien qu'on est
dans une clairière, mais...
On était dans ma chambre
il y a quelques secondes !
Oui, on n'y est plus,
ça, c'est sûr.
On est au Pays de Galles,
en 1314,
pas très loin du château
de Beaumaris.
Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
On est en 1300... Combien ?
Comment tu veux
que je croie ça ?
Je ne sais pas,
je suis un robot.
Tu t'es téléporté.
Ça devrait suffire.
Ouais,
c'est vrai que dit comme ça...
De toute façon, tu n'aurais
pas dû t'approcher de moi
pendant le voyage temporel.
Je vais te renvoyer
dans ton époque.
Non !
Non, non, non ! Surtout pas !
Tu m'as dit que tu savais
où était Iris.
Je... Je t'accompagne !
Désolé,
mais tu ne me sers à rien.
Mmh, sauf si tu sais
te battre à l'épée.
- Euh... Non.
- Mmh...
Pas grave, tu pourras toujours
servir de leurre
dans une situation délicate.
Ouais, ouais, ça, je sais faire,
le leurre !
Bon, où est Iris ?
D'après ses traces temporelles,
elle serait dans ce château,
là-bas.
Et tu viens d'où, exactement ?
- Du futur.
- Ah, j'en étais sûr !
Et t'as un nom du genre
C3XZ ou...
Je suis un robot,
donc j'ai un nom
avec des chiffres
et des lettres ?
Ouais, comme R2-D2...
Non, je ne suis pas
un vulgaire robot.
Je suis très respecté
dans mon époque
et je m'appelle Eliot.
Waouh ! Eliot-27 ?
Juste... Eliot.
C'est très raciste
envers les robots.
C'est robot-phobe.
Ça te plairait que je t'appelle
Thomas-54 ?
Eh, c'était le nom
de mon Skyblog !
Eh, mais c'est quoi le trou
que t'as dans le ventre, là ?
Rien. N'y touche pas.
Si, si, avec le bouton, là !
Ah, mais ça brûle !
Eh, mais...
Mais c'est du café !
Eliot, tu fais du café, mais...
Mais t'es une machine à café !
Pas du tout !
Souhaitez-vous du sucre ?
Bah... 2.
Bon, OK, tu m'as grillé.
Mais je sais faire
plein d'autres trucs.
Et aussi, c'est vrai, un...
café d'exception arabica.
Avec la machine KB-28,
un café savoureux et corsé.
D'accord. Ah !
Ah, on y est. C'est bon.
Waouh !
Eh, ils baissent le pont levis.
C'est sympa.
On est accueillis
par une dizaine d'hommes,
regarde, Eliot,
qui ont des regards menaçants !
Oh, putain ! Merde, Eliot !
Ils vont nous fusiller !
Pas d'inquiétude, le fusil sera
inventé dans plus de 100 ans.
Ah ! Tu me rassures, Eliot.
Ils vont plutôt nous transpercer
avec des flèches ou des lances.
Ne faites pas un pas de plus,
vils intrus !
Ou on vous transperce
avec nos flèches et nos lances !
Tu vois ?
Euh, Eliot...
Rassure-moi, si ça se passe mal,
tu peux remonter le temps
et tout va bien, c'est ça ?
Si une lance te transperce
la tête,
ça sert à rien de remonter
le temps, t'es juste mort.
Par contre, je peux t'enterrer
dans l'époque de ton choix.
- Non, ça... Ça ira.
- Laisse-moi faire.
- Oyez, valeureux soldats.
- Qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?
Nous venons en paix.
Pourquoi qu'on devrait
vous croire ?
Eh, compagnons, regardez
l'accoutrement de ces gueux !
Ils viennent pas de chez nous !
- Tuons-les !
Chers gens, ne faites pas
attention à nos accoutrements.
On vient offrir nos services
à votre roi.
Je suis un chevalier en armure.
Écoutez.
Et mon compagnon de route
aux vêtements originaux
est un troubadour.
- Quoi ?
- Prouvez-le !
Ouais, Eliot, c'est quoi,
un troubadour ?
Chante quelque chose.
Vous voyez ?
C'est un mensonge !
- Tuons-les !
Allez, Thomas !
Je connais rien comme chanson,
moi !
Mort de Thomas
car il ne veut pas chanter
dans 5... 4... 3... 2...
- 1...
- OK ! OK ! OK !
Euh...
Libérée
Délivrée
Je ne mentirai plus jamais
Libérée, délivrée
Je connais plus après
J'adore cette chanson.
Elle est simple et entraînante.
Oh, yes.
On cherche d'ailleurs un hymne
pour notre nation.
Elle me semble parfaite.
Entrez, mes amis !
Nous acceptons votre
hospitalité, mon bon ami.
Oui, mes chers gens, l'amabilité
que vous portez...
Tais-toi,
tu vas nous faire démasquer.
Ouais, ouais,
t'as raison, Eliot,
j'ai voulu faire comme toi,
c'était nul.
Allez offrir vos services
à la reine.
Elle se situe
au fond du château.
Yes, pas de lance dans le crâne,
Eliot, on a trop géré !
Bon, euh, on va trouver Iris...
Voilà !
On n'a qu'à se disperser.
On cherche discrètement
chaque recoin du château.
Si l'un de nous trouve Iris,
eh ben,
il fait un cri de pigeon pour...
On va demander à la reine
si elle a vu Iris.
Ouais, on va faire ce que tu dis
finalement, Eliot.
Attends, t'es sûr
qu'elle est bien ici, Iris ?
J'ai capté des traces d'elle
dans cet endroit
et cette temporalité.
OK, très bien, mais pourquoi
tu la cherches, d'ailleurs ?
Il sort d'où, lui ?
Il m'a fait peur, le con !
Oyez, ma reine !
Voici des visiteurs.
Chers visiteurs...
KB-28 ?
C'est toi, KB-28 ?
La machine KB-28,
pour un café d'exception.
- Bonjour, Iris.
- Iris ?
Thomas ?
Mais qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?
Mais non, toi !
Toi, qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?
C'est vrai, ça.
Que fout l'ex-copine de Thomas
sur un trône au Moyen Âge ?
Moi, je sais. Je sais tout.
Je sais même la fin.
Mais pour toi, il va falloir
attendre le prochain épisode.
L'épopée temporelle
ne fait que commencer.
Et nos personnages
s'apprêtent à traverser...
bien des épreuves.